[Music]
i have plenty of everything including
opinions real housewives of salt lake
city cast member jenny nguyen fired from
the bravo show after her past racist
social media posts resurfaced the
network released this statement on
tuesday announcing bravo ceased filming
with jenny and she will no longer be a
cast member in the franchise continuing
quote we recognize we failed to take
appropriate action once her offensive
social media posts were brought to our
attention moving forward we will work to
improve our processes to ensure we make
better informed and more thoughtful
casting decisions wynn's old posts which
were largely anti-black lives matter
came to light last week sparking her
co-stars to speak out that's was
upsetting for me to see that meredith
marks tweeted the word vile and a couple
days later clarified her tweet in a new
statement writing quote i am sickened by
my co-workers racist and prejudicial
posts that recently surfaced i do not
stand behind or support these posts in
any way shape or form
franchise executive producer andy cohen
also reacted to the controversy on his
radio show the posts were
very upsetting rightfully and disgusting
a source recently told et that the women
of salt lake city are quote outraged
over the posts which became a topic of
conversation as they started filming
their next season our source says jenny
filmed scenes for season three including
a sit-down confrontation with at least
one co-star to discuss the social media
scandal however at this time it's
unclear if or how bravo might use those
scenes they could be cut into season two
which is still airing to wrap up jenny's
story or to leave it on the cutting room
floor
cast member jen shaw also reacted to the
racist post saying she must stand up on
behalf of her husband and sons who are
african-american also writing that she's
quote deeply offended and how quote
infuriating it was to see jenny's
racially insensitive comments on social
media
jenny and i have been friends for over
10 years we were both pregnant together
housewife lisa barlow also released a
statement revealing her disappointment
by the resurface post saying quote the
posts were harmful and hurtful to a
community i love i don't condone those
and i'm completely anti-racist so
you know i hope um everyone does better
but i definitely don't condone those
jenny's posts were reportedly created in
the height of the black lives matter
movement in 2020 and the posts which
have since been deleted from facebook
consisted of racially offensive memes
mocking protesters and comparing them to
thugs wynn apologized for the post
writing quote at the time i thought i
was speaking out against violence but
i've since learned how offensive and
hurtful my words were i regret those
posts and am sincerely sorry for the
pain they caused you know my family's
toy stuff when e.t spoke with meredith
marks ahead of season two she opened up
about what it was like to have wynn step
in as a new member of the cast and her
attempt at playing peacemaker between
marx and jen shaw's heated fight i think
it's a little bit tricky when someone
who is
new to a group is trying to navigate
issues that were pre-existing
so um
i don't know i mean given the
circumstances you know
it's very heated
um you know
i am not one who gets easily agitated
but when you've pissed me off watch out
like it's not a joke
and um and i was there um so
given all the circumstances i i kind of
have to give jenny a little credit there
because
you know
it was not an easy situation so you know
bless her for trying i mean
it was tough